[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing for
Tuesday May 2nd I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
the surge in generative artificial
intelligence has led more people to
wonder whether or even when AI could
replace Us in some roles but maybe
that's not such a bad thing maybe an AI
version of you could take on some of
your workload our senior personal Tech
columnist Joanna Stern tried this out
with an AI clone of herself if you want
to see what that looks like there's
another video here on YouTube Joanna is
with me now to talk through how are AI
cloning experiment worked and why she
tried it Joanna first off am I talking
to the real Joanna or the AI Joanna Hey
Zoe thanks for having me on real Joanna
has outsourced this task to me now okay
no this is me but I am very interested
in having her come on the show would
save me some time yeah maybe next time
she can Be Our Guest talk us through how
you built that AI clone of of yourself I
used two different companies and tools
to work on this project the first was a
video and voice own from a company
called Synthesia this company makes
video clones you can go on the website
or on YouTube and watch this video of me
where it really looks and sounds like me
more looks than sounds but it's creepy I
mean you're gonna be like oh yeah I
guess that that person doesn't really
move their head in the right ways or
doesn't move their hands but it is a
full-on artificial intelligence clone so
I worked with that company and the way I
worked with them was I actually went to
a studio I recorded video with them I
recorded audio with them they took that
back they use that as training data to
create the Clone I then got access to a
web tool where I can just type in
whatever I want AI Joanna to say and
boom she says whatever I want her to say
the other tool I worked with was called
11 labs and I had started to hear about
how compelling the audio quality was
with this and so I decided to test this
out and this is just for voice and it is
crazy good in my opinion all I had had
to do there though I didn't have to go
to a studio I just uploaded previous
tracks that I had of my voice and within
two minutes it had the Clone ready and
so I can just go in there type in
whatever I want AI Joanna to say that's
exactly what I did with the line you
just heard on this and there she says it
so it sounds like there's two AI
doppelgangers here there's the video Ai
and there's the voice AI let's start
with the voice talk us through how you
use the AI voice clone how did you test
it out I had this dream with this
project that AI Joanna could replace me
for the day sort of a Ferris
bueller-like Day where I just you know
I'm home sleeping watching TV hanging
with my kids but AI Joanna does
everything else and so one of the things
I did was I called my family I called my
sister specifically and at first my
sister really did think it was me within
the first few seconds she definitely
didn't respond she wasn't like who is
this and then as it went on she sort of
realized okay this is a recording and
the reason she said that was she said
that the quality of the call didn't
sound totally real so my AI voice didn't
really breathe enough is what she said
but if all of that was aside I think she
really would have fell for it especially
if it was really like an automated
conversation alright so that was your
family what about something more
official didn't you try to call your
bank too so many banks offer voice
Biometrics and this is just a way that
they verify it's you or one of the many
ways they can verify it's you is by
listening to your voice and saying oh
that sounds like her or that sounds like
him let's put her through to the
customer service rep without asking a
number of questions and so when I called
my Chase credit card it absolutely
worked I called I waited for the voice
biometric step I played the recording of
my voice clone saying my name and
address and boom I was put right through
to the customer service rep now yes we
did fool The Voice biometric but Chase
specifically says that they would
require other forms of identification
and other forms of verification to do
anything more in the account so if I was
really trying to use this to transfer
money or do something else on the
account Chase tells me there would be
other questions and verification steps
okay it sounds like AI Joanna was pretty
good on The Voice side what about on the
video side were you able to send her to
uh to any video calls to help your
Ferris Bueller's Day Off I did two tests
on the video and both were basically a
fail the first was create a tick tock
which I think was still very compelling
and I think one of the scariest things
of this experiment is that I can see
down the line this being compelling
enough being convincing enough to post
on Tick Tock and no one to really
question if this was me people who are
regular Watchers in my video definitely
said no this is not her she doesn't have
right hand movements she doesn't have
hand movements at all actually not a lot
of facial expression so there's still
work to be done there I also tried to
send my video clone really Ferris
Bueller style pumped her into my video
meetings Google meets for the day and I
didn't convince anybody sadly they just
noticed quickly that her posture was
very good which okay take a little bit
of a fence too and that she just again
didn't have any facial expressions and
sounded robotic so Joanna should we
expect AI Joanna to keep popping up in
your feed in your videos so I think this
is the interesting thing I still want to
use AI Joanna but I want to use her
behind the scenes I want to use the
voice technology I do a lot of video
work and I'm constantly needing to
re-record sentences to see if they fit
in certain parts or how we want to move
things around and there's a big process
to making the videos and we are starting
to use this kind of technology for
making it simpler for me not to always
have to record in that process so I
think a lot of the tools that we are
seeing with AI can be used in a way
behind the scenes and not necessarily
everything we see is AI generated as
much as I'd like to send AI Joanna on
your show or maybe see her in more
videos I don't think we're quite there
yet and also I would like to keep my job
fair enough all right that's the real
senior personal Tech columnist for the
Wall Street Journal Joanna Stern Joanna
thanks for joining us and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign